attacke in london ein mann sticht auf
passanten ein
die polizei erschießt den angreifer und
geht von terror aus kampf ums klima
hunderttausende demonstrieren das
klimapaket der regierung fällt im
bundesrat teilweise durch und wieder ein
neuer termin der pannen flughafen ber
soll nun ende oktober 2020 fertig sein
neun jahre nach dem ersten versuch
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster mit namen bei den heute
nachrichten um 19 uhr sport es auch
dabei norbert lehmann ist dafür an
meiner seite meiner familie und wir
beginnen mit einer nachricht aus london
die am nachmittag aufschreckte auf der
landen bridge sticht ein mann wahllos
auf passanten ein und verletzt sie die
polizei erschießt den verdächtigen der
eine sprengstoffweste zu tragen schien
die polizei geht von terror aus der
tatort liegt mitten im herzen der
britischen hauptstadt unweit des towers
auf landen und das büro market nach der
tat wurden brücke und umgebung
weiträumig abgesperrt es war gegen 14
uhr ortszeit als die london bridge wie
schon vor zwei jahren wieder zum tatort
eines anschlags wurde die
unübersichtliche szene wurde von
passanten auf handyvideos gefilmt es
scheint als wenn der verdächtige von
zivilisten zu boden gerungen wurde
dann kämpften die herbeigeeilten
polizisten mit ihm bis ein beamter
zurücktrat auf ihn schoss und tödlich
traf dies ließ bei vielen die vermutung
aufkommen dass der täter eine
sprengstoffweste trug der chef der
londoner anti terror einheit bestätigte
am nachmittag dass sie die ereignisse
wie einen vorfall mit terroristischem
hintergrund behandeln wir können
bestätigen dass es sich nach unserer
einschätzung bei dem gegenstand der um
seinen körper geschnallt war um eine
attrappe handelt mehrere personen wurden
durch messerstiche verletzt die gegend
um die brücke weiträumig abgesperrt ich
hörte so etwas wie explosionen aber dann
ist mir erst hinterher klar geworden
dass es schüsse waren
es war eine schwierige situation denn
sobald alle anfangen wegzurennen fängst
du auch an um deine eigene sicherheit zu
fürchten das wichtigste war so schnell
wie möglich weg zu kommen
du weißt einfach nicht was passiert
bei der london bridge attacke im juni
2017 kamen acht opfer und drei
attentäter ums leben
diese erinnerung wurden nun wieder
wachgerufen auch wenn der hintergrund
des heutigen vorfalls noch nicht geklärt
ist die frage an andreas stamm in london
hat sich der terrorverdacht inzwischen
erhärtet andreas wie ist die lage bei
ihnen
die polizei hatte sich da etwas
kryptisch geäußert muss man sagen indem
sie erklärt hat wir betrachten das
sozusagen als einen terroristischen
vorfall das heißt zwei dinge erstens man
ist sich da noch nicht sicher man
schließt kein weiteres motiv aus etwa
ein amoklauf und zweitens es können eben
notfallpläne sozusagen in stellung
gebracht werden das so dass anti terror
polizei eben ausdrückt was sie dann auch
tut und das heißt dass zurzeit noch
hinter mir in dem gebiet das weiträumig
abgeriegelt ist sozusagen diese
einheiten noch immer jeden den letzten
zweifel ausräumen wollen und dann noch
mal alles durchsuchen
der premierminister sieht das ganze
etwas anders in einer ansprache vor
wenigen minuten hat er erklärt dass er
glaubt die polizei bestätigt den
terrorismus verdacht dazu muss man sagen
es ist wahlkampf in großbritannien und
am 12 dezember wird gewählt feststeht
und das hat die polizei erklärt wer am
wochenende in london ist er muss
vermehrt mit schwer bewaffneten anti
terror polizei einheiten auf der straße
rechnen
als reine sicherheitsmaßnahme danke
ihnen andreas für diesen
situationsbericht vor der klimakonferenz
in madrid wollten die klimaaktivisten
von freddys for future noch mal für
ihren kampf gegen die erderwärmung
trommeln und so viele menschen wie
möglich auf die straße bringen und zwar
weltweit in fast 160 ländern
melbourne in australien gehörten zu den
ersten städten in denen sich menschen
zum protest zusammen fanden in indien
versammelten sich studenten in der stadt
kolkata in lissabon zogen die
demonstranten in richtung des parlaments
eine der größten aktionen in deutschland
fand in berlin statt
roman leskovar
zehntausende allein in berlin auch am
vierten weltweiten klima streiktag gehen
vielerorts die menschen auf die straßen
trotz der großen resonanz ein gewisser
protest verdruss ist mittlerweile
herauszuhören unzufriedenheit mit der
politik die auf ihre forderungen nicht
eingehen
ein knappes jahr nach beginn der
deutschen frei dsv future streiks fällt
die bilanz unterschiedlich aus ich würde
sagen dass man schon zufrieden sein kann
damit darf auf jeden fall die
aufmerksamkeit auf den klimaschutz
ausgerichtet wird man hat einfach das
gefühl wir stehen hier auf der straße
haben irgendwie junge menschen die das
ganze wirklich angeht wir haben
wissenschaftler hinter uns die wirklich
sagen es ist so ernst ist stimmt was die
leute hier fordern und es einfach
besteht das gefühl es kommt nicht an
der protest nicht zufällig auf den
heutigen tag gelegt kommende woche
beginnt die weltklimakonferenz in madrid
doch auch den organisatoren bleibt nicht
verborgen politische erfolge hat die
bewegung bisher wenig vorzuweisen
einige frei dsv future aktivisten ziehen
bereits schlussfolgerungen es gibt in
vielen städten andere aktionen neben den
streiks oder anstelle der streiks wo
leute sagen okay der streik ist auch
eine aktion des zivilen ungehorsams hat
ein riesen debatte ausgelöst aber
anscheinend hat es nicht gereicht wir
gehen uns den schritt weiter und
blockieren zb vorerst aber sorgt
prominente unterstützung wie die musik
größe sieht für neuen schwung
[Musik]
und hält die gemüter zumindest heute
wieder ein wenig aufstellen getrieben
auch durch den druck der straße hat die
koalition in berlin ein gesetzespaket
zum klimaschutz geschnürt das war heute
thema im bundesrat teile des pakets
können nun in kraft treten etwa der co2
preis für benzin und diesel heizöl und
erdgas langsam teurer machen soll
andere teile hingegen wurden gestoppt
nämlich die bei denen die länder
finanzielle einbußen befürchten andreas
ruppert berichtet gesprächsbedarf gab es
reichlich bei dem ministerpräsidenten
heute im bundesrat die länderchefs waren
sich einig und verweigerten der
bundesregierung die zustimmung bei
teilen des klimapakets das klimapaket
ist richtig und wichtig aber es sind
noch nicht alle punkte geklärt
insbesondere nicht die finanzfragen die
natürlich basis sind für ein
funktionierendes klimapaket den ländern
geht also ums geld sie fürchten
steuerausfälle in ihren kassen
beispielsweise durch die senkung der
mehrwertsteuer für bahntickets durch die
erhöhung der pendlerpauschale und bei
den zuschüssen für energetisches bauen
das problem ist ein bisschen die länder
haben steuerausfälle der buntheit
steuerausfälle
aber der bund hat ein ein name system
und die länder nicht also über den
emissionshandel
das sind glauben wir dass da einfach ein
stück weit vom bund mehr entgegenkommen
ist noch ist nicht klar wie dieses
entgegenkommen seitens des bundes
aussehen könnte ich hoffe sehr dass wir
uns jetzt noch schnell mit den ländern
einigen können weil wenn wir uns nicht
dieses jahr einigen dann kann am 11
wichtige dinge nicht in kraft treten
zum beispiel die absenkung des
fahrpreises für die bahn und auch beim
ausbau der windkraft gibt streit vor
allem die nordländer fordern vom bund
schnelleren netzausbau und die
sogenannte 1000 meter abstand regel
abzuschaffen
diese verhindere nämlich eine effektive
nutzung von erneuerbaren energien
das können die länder selbst regeln
machen wir übrigens über jahre
und warum sollen wir in
schleswig-holstein darunter leiden weil
es in anderen bundesländern größere
widerstände gibt und dort regeln
eingefordert werden das klima paket ist
geschnürt doch die exakte ausgestaltung
mit den ländern ist noch ziemlich
undurchsichtig anstieg der treibhausgase
fortschreitende erderwärmung auch das
aktuelle politbarometer hat fragen zum
klimawandel gestellt große oder sehr
große sorgen deswegen macht sich eine
deutliche mehrheit insgesamt 65 prozent
und das urteil über die klimapolitik der
bundesregierung sie tue zu viel für den
klimaschutz sagen 13 prozent gerade
richtig 24 die deutliche mehrheit aber
60 prozent sagt die bundesregierung tue
zu wenig und das gesamte zdf
politbarometer gibt es ab 22 uhr im
heute-journal und jederzeit online auf
heute.de unter anderem mit der bewertung
der zehn wichtigsten spitzenpolitiker in
deutschland nach audi und bmw hat jetzt
auch daimler einen massiven stellenabbau
angekündigt weltweit sollen in den
kommenden drei jahren mindestens 10.000
arbeitsplätze wegfallen
dazu will der stuttgarter konzern in
erster linie frei werdende stellen nicht
nachbesetzt und die altersteilzeit
ausweiten
betriebsbedingte kündigungen soll es
zumindest deutschlandweit in den
nächsten zehn jahren nicht geben
das problem stellen abbauen zu müssen
hat die branche ja insgesamt valerie
haller an der frankfurter börse
woran liegt es eigentlich ja die branche
bekommt die schwache weltkonjunktur mit
voller wucht zu spüren die absätze gehen
zurück auch verschlingen diesel
altlasten gewaltige summen ja und
gleichzeitig müssen die autobauer
milliarden investieren denn
elektromobilität und in die entwicklung
von zukunftstechnologien aus der krise
sehen die autobauer offenbar nur einen
ausweg den radikalen sparkurs
die hiobsbotschaften kommen schlag auf
schlag diese woche die aktuellste von
daimler mindestens 10.000 stellen
weltweit fallen weg audi will 9500 jobs
streichen bmw will auf den einsatz von
leiharbeitern künftig verzichten
zulieferer mit eingeschlossen hat die
branche allein dieses jahr den abbau von
50.000 arbeitsplätzen an
kündigt experten gehen davon aus dass in
den kommenden jahren noch deutlich mehr
stellen wegfallen könnten
zumal auch zulieferbetriebe wie bosch
und continental schon massive
sparprogramme angekündigt haben die
mobilitäts wende ist nun endgültig bei
deutschlands schlüsselindustrie
angekommen danke für ihre analyse
valerie haller an der frankfurter börse
trotz krise in der autobranche und
schwächelnder konjunktur kommt von der
bundesagentur für arbeit eine positive
nachricht die zahl der arbeitslosen war
im november auf dem niedrigsten stand
seit der wiedervereinigung nämlich bei 2
millionen 180.000 menschen das sind
24.000 weniger als im oktober
die quote bleibt bei 4,8 prozent im
vergleich zum november des vorjahres
waren 6000 menschen weniger ohne job
einen tag nach den blutigen protesten im
irak mit mehr als 40 toten hat
ministerpräsident macht die seinen
rücktritt angekündigt damit wolle er
verhindern dass das land in noch mehr
gewalt und chaos abgleitet
seit wochen gehen die menschen im irak
auf die straße um gegen korruption
misswirtschaft und den ihrer meinung
nach zu nehmenden iranischen einfluss zu
demonstrieren
massenhafter kindesmissbrauch in
bergisch gladbach eine festnahme im
oktober bringt den stein ins rollen
denn auf dem handy eines verdächtigen
entdeckt die polizei in nordrhein
westfalen ein chat netzwerk mit bis zu
1800 mitgliedern der fall zieht immer
größere kreise jetzt gibt es schon mehr
als 30 beschuldigte sie sollen fotos und
videos von kindern mit tausenden geteilt
haben thomas münten fasst zusammen
polizei köln sonderkommission berg seit
wochen müssen sich 300 beamte hier
täglich grausame bilder chats und videos
anschauen
manuela ist einer der ermittlerinnen ihr
nachname soll nicht genannt werden
die tat an sich ist passiert die kann
ich leider nicht mehr ändern aber ich
kann vielleicht in zukunft ändern
in der zukunft ändern dass der täter
nicht weiter zugriff auf dieses kind hat
wenn man sich videos und bilder unter
diesem aspekt anschaut
das gibt einen letztendlich die
motivation hinter der arbeit und damit
zurechtzukommen
immer tiefer wird der einblick in das
wohl internationale netzwerk in dem
filme und bilder getauscht aber auch
absprachen zum missbrauch eigenen von
stiefkindern getroffen wurden für das
innenministerium greifen alte täter muss
dann nicht mehr die soziale struktur ist
eigentlich das bild aus der mitte der
gesellschaft die sind im berufsleben
sind sozial stabil sind familienväter
das ist ein 1 1 täter fällt was aus
allen schichten der gesellschaft kommen
kann
mehr als 30 tatverdächtige sollen bisher
identifiziert worden seien
zigtausende stunden videos und millionen
fotos wurden sichergestellt
die ermittler sollen bald auch mit
computergenerierten fake bildern
arbeiten dürfen um zugang zu den
kriminellen netzwerken zu erreichen das
ist deshalb wichtig und gut weil wir
dann mit verdeckten ermittlern und
diesen chats annähern können in diesen
chats auch den eintritt darüber gewinnen
können und dort teilnehmen können um
darüber dann chat teilnehmer zu
identifizieren und dort andauerndes
sexuelle missbräuche zu unterbinden jede
durchsuchung bei neuen tatverdächtigen
bringt weitere riesige datenmengen die
gesichtet werden müssen
der hauptstadtflughafen ber hat einen
neuen eröffnungstermin es ist sein
siebter danach soll er in rund elf
monaten am 31 oktober 2020 seinen
betrieb aufnehmen
ursprünglich sollten hier schon am 30
oktober 2011 die ersten flieger starten
und landen
nun soll es also neun jahre später so
weit sein
der bau dauert nicht nur länger sondern
ist auch teurer als geplant die kosten
stiegen von 2 auf rund sechseinhalb
milliarden euro carsten behrendt über
den berliner problem flughafen
hier soll ab dem 31 oktober 2020
geflogen werden versichert berlins
flughafenchef heute nach der sitzung
seines aufsichtsrats wir werden am 31
oktober den kommerziellen flugverkehr am
ber im neuen terminal aufnehmen und
werden dann in drei schritten bis zum 8
november von tegel zum br umziehen wir
sind sicher dass sie öffnen
der ber eine leidensgeschichte kosten
und bauzeit verdreifacht die größten
probleme der brandschutz massenhaft
falsch verlegte kabel nicht
funktionierende technik das chaos wurde
immer wieder unterschätzt der
aufsichtsrat heute entsprechend
vorsichtig wir sind nicht in einer
situation wo man sich auf lorbeeren
ausruhen können
wir haben defizite und wir haben eine
menge komplexen handlungsbedarf
trotzdem glauben wir wir schaffen das
bereits anfang der woche durften
journalisten einen blick ins terminal
werfen in br nur noch auffällig wenig
baustelle überall koffer für den
testbetrieb der gepäck anlage die
botschaft alles im griff sieht er alles
fix und fertig aus am ber so als könnte
es sofort losgehen aber genau das hatten
wir schon mal
2012 kurz befördern die eröffnung
spektakulär geplatzt ist ende frühjahr
2020 soll der bau fertig sein erst dann
kann die zuständige behörde den
flughafen freigeben und die finalen
tests beginnen am ber bleibt es ein
wettlauf gegen die zeit retten können
abgeschlossen werden ab jetzt und nun
zum fußball und zu drei deutschen
auswärtssiegen gestern abend in der
europa league norbert ja genau wolfsburg
hat damit die zwischenrunde schon bei
erreicht gladbach und frankfurt stehen
kurz davor für die eintracht eine
wahrlich besondere begegnung gegen
arsenal in london
sie begegnete nämlich ihren fans die gar
nicht im stadion sein durften
staunen bei der eintracht trotz verbots
wegen ausschreitungen hatten sich
zahlreiche frankfurt fans irgendwie doch
ins stadion
wir waren sehr überrascht darüber weil
wir eigentlich damit gerechnet haben
dass niemand da sein wird so schön nicht
schön frankfurts leistung in halbzeit
eins viel zu harmlos folge der
ex-dortmunder ober milliarden führung
schnell kurz vor der pause in der
zweiten hälfte ein ganz anderes bild
frankfurt voller energie vor allem einer
eins zu eins daiichi kanada der japaner
der wenig später das 2 2 1 folgen lässt
sein erster doppelpack für frankfurt
bedeutet für arsenal das siebten
pflichtspiel nacheinander ohne sieg
trainer unai emery wird heute morgen
entlassen
gewinnt die eintracht in zwei wochen nun
gegen guimaraes wäre auch sie in der
europa league zwischenrunde zur
bundesliga für den einen ist es
definitiv sein erstes spiel als
hertha-trainer für den anderen könnte
ist sein letztes spiel sein als
bvb-coach das ligaduell berlin gegen
dortmund ist auch ein trainer duell
klinsmann gegen favre trainer duell vor
allem aber unterschiedliche stimmungen
gedrückt die in dortmund für farbe ist
wohl ein job ins spiel
ich konzentriere mich auf das
wesentliche nur in berlin und mein mann
fall ist unwichtig die chance auf
besserung in barcelona verpasst aber ist
nicht alles negativ haben nicht schlecht
gespielt in barcelona aber eben auch
nichts mitgenommen und jetzt wahrte die
hertha mit neuen cheftrainer der gute
laune verbreitet es macht spaß und das
spürt man eine unglaubliche energie her
projektleiter klinsmann hat wieder alles
auf links gedreht funktionsteam und ihm
aber wohl schon auf linie
alles steht hinter bartels' diesen
prozess jetzt da nach oben wieder zu
kommen zwei trainer ein duell und die
große hoffnung auf sonnigere zeiten
das war's wir haben noch eine
höchstleistung ganz anderer art aktuell
aus duisburg was hier aussieht wie ein
bällebad für erwachsene ist kulisse
eines neuen weltrekord mehr als 12.000
luftballons zusammengeknotet zu einer
gut 20 meter hohen riesenkrake
ihre vergänglichkeit haben die schöpfer
gleich mit eingeplant
die ballons sind aus naturkautschuk
biologisch abbaubar gut für echte
unterwasser tiere zum wetter das wird
teils sonnig teils wolkig zu den
einzelheiten gleich gunther tiersch so
viel für heute von uns marietta slomka
informiert sie punkt 22 uhr im
heute-journal und wir sind morgen wieder
für sich da um 19 uhr
danke für ihr interesse und einen
schönen start ins wochenende
[Musik]
und liebe zuschauer die nächte werden
bei uns jetzt wieder frostig aber
tagsüber bleibt es noch frostfrei
höchsttemperaturen um die 5 grad in
mitteleuropa anders im süden am
mittelmeer 15 bis 20 grad sehr mild das
wetter noch zum teil bis zu 25 grad und
wir bekommen da kommende nacht
verbreitet leichten frost zwischen null
und minus vier grad nur im nordwesten
bleibt es frostfrei und dazu wird meist
klar ist ziehen noch ein paar
schneeschauer durch über die
mittelgebirge erzgebirge zum beispiel
aber auch an den alpen haben wir ja noch
den regen den schnee und langsam sinkt
die schneefallgrenze bis in die
niederungen
morgen wird es dann in norddeutschland
ganz freundlich allerdings so von der
nordsee nach niedersachsen zum harz
ziehen sich die dichten wolken da kann
es noch mal ein regenschauer geben und
sie ziehen dann weiter richtung
erzgebirge wo es dann auch stark bewölkt
ist vielleicht gibt es dann mal ein
schneeschauer
auch im östlichen bayern ist die
bewölkung er stärker nach westen den
lockert auf und am rhein scheint
überwiegend die sonne die temperaturen
im osten etwas niedriger als im westen
das heißt da sind es dann im osten 1 bis
6 grad sonst im westen bis sieben oder
acht grad und die aussichten es bleibt
noch ziemlich kalt am sonntag mit schnee
und schneeregen im südwesten und auch in
der neuen woche geht es weiter
ein bisschen regen im norden oder auch
mal ein schneeschauer im süden ich
wünschen noch einen schönen abend und
machen sie's gut